in terms of non-believer and believer
there's um when you say believer
you also are kind of implying this um
uh the that the idea that aliens have
visited
or had made direct contact with humans
in some form
um there's also the the exploration and
the idea
of just alien intelligent intelligence
is out there in the universe
you know the drake equation estimating
how many
intelligent civilizations may be out
there how many have ever existed how
many are able to communicate with us
i mean when you just zoom out from our
own
little selfish perspective of earth and
look at the entirety let's say the milky
way galaxy but maybe even the universe
does the idea that there are intelligent
civilizations out there something that
you're excited about
or something that you're terrified about
that's a good question so basically
i would say i'm not so keen on it um
i think that our relationship with
technology
as it is and as it as i hope it will go
will help us um survive
okay um i don't think we're
equipped to do it as we stand now but i
think that
if we can up our game or let's just put
it this way
if technology is an extension of
ourselves which it actually
is it will help us because it'll
probably be smarter than us okay
it'll help us survive in the ways in
which it determines best okay
that said um if there are
non-human intelligences out there
and they have more advanced you know
obviously
technologies than us and they actually
come and
the history of human engagement
with you know other cultures has not
gone well for cultures that are less
aggressive
so you see what i'm saying like it's not
a good idea
well i wonder where we stand on the
where humans stand the full spectrum of
aggression
well heck where are we now lex i mean
we're not too great here we're still
aggressing against each other no i know
but that that will give us a benefit
right
like oh or you're saying i thought
okay i see i just have a sense that
there may be a lot of
intelligences out there that are less
aggressive
because they've evolved past it we can't
assume that
no i know we can't assume that but like
if we can't assume it
then i'm gonna assume the worst
well that's that's uh uh despite the
fact that i'm
uh russian and think that life is
suffering i tend to assume
not the best but i i tend to assume that
there is a best
core to uh
to creatures to people into creatures
that ultimately wins out
i think there's an evolutionary
advantage
to being good to other living creatures
and so uh ultimately i think that if
there's intelligent
civilizations out there that prosper
sufficiently to be able to
travel across the great spans of
space that uh they've evolved
past silly aggression
that uh it's more likely in my mind to
be
deeply cooperative so like growth over
destruction
like growth does not require destruction
i think but if you see the universe as a
ultimately a place where it's highly
constrained in resources that are
necessary
for traveling across space
and time then uh perhaps aggression is
necessary in order to
aggress against others that are desiring
to get access to those resources
i don't know i tend to try to be
optimistic
on that front i think i'm emotionally
optimistic and intellectually
non-optimistic uh yeah
i guess i'm that i'm there with you i i
tend to believe that the uh
happiness and deep fulfillment in life
is found in that emotional place
the intellectual place is really useful
for building cool new technologies
and ideas and so on but happiness is in
the emotional place
and there it pays off to be optimistic i
think
you